just give yourself time to step away
from work and do something else that
doesn't involve work don't take a break
go on the phone go on your phones grow
on tick tock like completely separate
the two create a personal life that's
separate from your work life
when anxiety stress and the pressure of
a life comes on a content creator it can
be the perfect storm for burn out we're
going to be going deeper into this
conversation and we've had several
conversations like this here on the
podcast because as a content creator
there are certain signs when it's going
to happen and today we're going to be
sharing that with our friend modern
millie who is our guest on the show my
name is heather torres and you are
listening to the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
youtube channel and your influence on
that youtube channel and turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit online business now burnout is
something that i personally have
experienced at different levels
depending on the pressures of life and
the seasons of life as a content creator
and entrepreneur this is vital that we
have these conversations that we see the
signs that are happening so let's get
into today's featured conversation with
sean cannell and modern millie
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm excited to have modern millie back
instagram expert youtuber 160 000
subscribers but i'm so passionate about
this conversation because we're here at
an event and we were talking at the
speaker party and she's sharing a little
bit about
her burnout season and what's kind of
crazy is i think at one point or another
all of us as creators as entrepreneurs
as business owners
have felt the early onset of burnout we
could be in burnout right now we may not
know it and there was a season um where
there was a proliferation of articles
about youtubers burning out we're
hearing about tick tock earth burning
out and i do believe there's some unique
pressures
and some unique dynamics that actually
really impact our community here at the
think media podcast
that we should be aware of and so
eventually we're going to be talking
about some three tips if you might feel
like you're in burnout or you want to
determine if you are we'll talk about
some diagnostics and some tests we'll
learn from this but i mean we got to
dive right into the story yeah lead us
through what happened what was happening
before
and and you found yourself in burnout
what's the story right in 2020 it was
the first time i experienced burnout and
i just
had major anxiety anytime i would open
the instagram app or youtube app so i
just took a few months off took a break
and i was like wow i'm burnt out i can't
what was happening up until that point
how much
hustle how much work were you doing what
was your life and career like i
was let go for my job
was planning a wedding my dog was
diagnosed with an autoimmune disorder
disorder and they said she had 80
mortality rates so she was probably
going to pass she ended up living so
i'll say she's fine now but it was just
life was crazy i was posting every day
to instagram
and there was no really warning signs of
hey you're going to be burnt out i
didn't know i thought i was elite i
thought i was above it and i was like i
already have great boundaries set i'm
fine and one day
after getting let go finally my dog was
like healthy
and then we had to cancel our wedding
once everything just lifted off my
shoulders that's when it all set in and
i was like i'm done
i'm done so that was like the first
burnout i ever experienced wow so then
how many years leading up of content
creation specifically and how many hours
a week would you say you were working on
in business and entrepreneurship it was
really maybe one year into my journey it
wasn't really long at all
and
i was trying to do it full-time so i was
working maybe it was five months doing
that full-time i had to get another job
because i was like i should probably get
a job to pay for a wedding shortly after
covet hit and i got let go so just
bouncing a lot just trying to juggle a
lot of hours in work and with my passion
so it hits what did it feel like what uh
how did you know i mean and what were
some of the symptoms and what was like
so the first time which was 2020 i was
just exhausted anytime i looked at my
phone anxiety would increase right away
i really had to distance myself from
social media and then the second time
which is the more recent time back 2021
august i got really sick
and it didn't really creep up on me i
had just finished a course launch my
first course launch ever
and
i came home from a new york retreat
and i fainted
wow randomly in the middle of about to
record a youtube video
you're alone i mean that sounds scary it
was terrifying so i was sitting in front
of the camera getting ready to record
next thing i know i'm in my living room
telling my husband i'm fainting and
falling to the floor i blacked out
everything in between
and that was the
scariest thing because it's like i don't
know how i got here panic at my first
panic attack happened right there of
just like
extreme anxiety can't breathe what's
happening
and
from there it was maybe august 7th all
the way through november i was getting
sick i was having panic attacks like i
had this mysterious illness i had 105
degrees tested for everything
and
that fever would come and go for months
wow
and so
i mean
it's i'm so glad you're here today yeah
and you're you've navigated through that
season and i want to hear more details
of the story but let's kind of share
some of the tips you've learned in
lessons that we could maybe encourage
ourselves with the first one was was
dope weight what do you mean by that
i think
i was
i don't know i was waiting to feel
burnout before i started taking the
measures to protect myself and to really
take care of myself so
because i wasn't feeling
oh i'm i'm fine i'm fine i don't need to
take care of myself yet i'm fine
that's the problem with entrepreneurs
yeah is we're usually fine sure
like we're fine with stress
we
thrive under pressure a lot of us thrive
under that pressure of
continuing to work and we like work we
love what we do and so we think oh we
love what we do
so we can just do that and be fine yeah
and that was my problem was
well i love what i do i'm not feeling
stressed like i don't think i'm feeling
stressed my brain wasn't recognizing it
my body felt it though wow and so that's
why my body had to retaliate and be like
nah milly we're gonna sit your butt down
you might not feel it but your body's
feeling it we're gonna let make you rest
yeah so did you
slow down your work pace
what did you learn in
as you at this point
you're saying encouraging us don't wait
do the things before this happens but it
did happen to you yeah so what are the
things that you started to do now
you know the simple things starting with
the simple things like drinking more
water
eating foods that nurture you
incorporating movement the biggest thing
that i've learned is to complete the
stress cycle
so usually we think
when i complete the stress cycle i'm
ticking off boxes on my to-do list so
you have your to-do list and those
things are giving you stress and then
you're gonna check boxes and once you
check that box woo stress is gone wrong
you have the stressors and the stress
the stressors is your list of to do and
then you have the stress which is the
physical response to the stressors that
needs to be resolved and that is best
resolved through movement so
incorporating some sort of walking every
day or maybe going to the gym going to
the beach yoga something to get my body
moving to resolve those stress responses
that's been the biggest thing for me and
then finally setting those boundaries
hey we're gonna get back into our
featured conversation with our guests
but i wanted to let you know that we
have a free master class happening right
now to help you grow your youtube
channel if you go to
thinkmasterclass.com you can learn the
secrets to success on how to win on
youtube that's thinkmasterclass.com
and if you're new to the show we want to
welcome you and ask you to subscribe if
you're watching on youtube you can hit
that subscribe button or you can
subscribe wherever you listen to this
content on thanks for being a part of
our community and let's get back into
our featured conversation
so don't wait to
start taking care of your health don't
wait to get moving when it's tempting to
just grind all day and be in front of a
screen all day and edit all day
don't wait to really be aware of stress
sirs and the stress and then you kind of
touched on number two
set boundaries so what have you learned
what advice can you give us about
setting boundaries to avoid burnout i've
set some
hard boundaries and it's still hard for
me to stick to these
but setting those boundaries of a start
time and an end time for my work and
this is what works for me people will
have different types of boundaries for
me
my start time is 10 a.m
my me time is before 10 a.m so that's my
boundary of in my starting my day
nurturing myself whatever that looks
like 10 am i go to work and then i'm
gonna work for four hours
ten to two i'm working two is closing my
laptop i'm done after two set that hard
boundary even if i want to keep going
and i could keep going because i love
what i do stop
go on a walk eat like eat food who would
have thought and just give yourself time
to step away from work and do something
else that doesn't involve work don't
take a break go on the phone go on your
phones girl on tick tock like completely
separate the two create a personal life
that's separate from your work life it's
really good so what boundaries think
media podcasts do you need to set who do
you need to communicate with maybe
talking to a partner a loved one um
talking to your calendar and setting
some hard boundaries um that's such a
great tip for navigating and overcoming
burnout and then
your next tip is check yourself what do
you mean by that
i mean
setting boundaries
it's part of it right you can set
boundaries be like whoa i set boundaries
and then you stick to those boundaries
for a week
but
naturally you want to fall into those
habits of like okay well i did a week i
feel great
now i'm gonna fall back into my pattern
of working 10 hours a day
so you have to constantly be checking
yourself and being like am i sticking to
these boundaries am i actually sticking
to them for me sometimes i don't stick
to them i have to check myself and be
like no you need to stick to them you
need time for yourself you need to spend
time with your husband like you need to
nurture the other relationships that are
outside of work and prioritize your
yourself your self-care the
relationships that really value
that you value outside of work so always
every week being like could i do better
did i
like you say one percent better could i
get one percent better with setting
boundaries this week that's really
strong this is so powerful millie you
know one of the commitments my wife and
i made this year was to really honor the
sabbath in terms of like really
disconnecting we read a book called the
ruthless elimination of hurry and like
really getting off our phone and really
actually not shopping that day because
there's other days to do it and so it's
not like overly dogmatic but like really
taking a day that's different that's set
apart and you know we're people of faith
so
we believe god wove that into the fabric
of the universe that we're to work six
but rest on the seventh and what i've
learned is that that is such a day
of checking yourself it's a day of like
realizing maybe how stressed out i was
trying to slow down realizing that
there's transitional emotional things
you know realizing that there's also
just margin now created to go on a walk
and leave our phones at home and it's
changed everything and i mean it kind of
makes sense because it's if like we're
breathing out for six days it's like a
chance to catch our breath and breathe
in
on uh having a time to check ourselves
so that's something we've been doing
we've really been learning from and it's
been so powerful yeah and when you think
about the creation story itself what did
god do on the seventh day
rested and so making sure that we're
having that time to rest because when
you rest this is something that blew my
mind
when you rest you're able to show up
even better and stronger and you have a
more clear mind i was just on the grind
of oh i need to show up every day i need
to show up every day
but that's not true because when you
take the time off to rest
when you then choose to show up
that's when you're more fulfilled and
you could show up even better more
exuberant and clear-minded do your best
work
i heard james altersher say don't buy
into the myth of not getting enough
sleep ariana huffington wrote you know
the sleep revolution she passed out and
woke up in a puddle of blood because of
pushing it so hard and so man check
yourself before you wreck yourself
as the great theologian ice cube said uh
but certainly
um
uh this idea of navigating the road of
burnout and as entrepreneurs type a
driven
check yourself is like the point because
it's i can find that it's a month goes
by and we're like wow that wasn't the
best month but we can reset
we get back to it so i hope you
encourage think media podcast to
to not be critical this definitely
shouldn't lead to guilt check yourself
for burnout but to get one percent
better because we want to be we don't
just want the 15 minutes of fame the
short thing that social media's pressure
and youtube's pressure is like oh i got
to frantically grow as much as i can
because it's like no i'm a lot more
interested in being healthy and around 5
10
20 years from now than just 20 minutes
of a viral video and so millie really
appreciate you grateful you came on the
podcast for people that want to check
you out on youtube and instagram where
can they find you my handle on instagram
is at it's modern millie and then on
youtube you can look up modern millie
well i hope that that was an encouraging
conversation to you and if you're in the
comments on youtube i'd love to know
have you experienced burnout before and
what were some of the steps that you had
to take to get yourself back to normal i
know for me personally there's been
several seasons where i've experienced
being on the cusp of burnout
particularly and you know for me it has
come with being overwhelmed with too
many decisions or overwhelmed with all
of the expectations that one i've put on
myself but that i've let others put on
me as well so if you feel like you may
be heading into that season you know
we've had some crazy years over the past
few years and as a content creator
trying to stay on that hamster wheel of
always producing content always showing
up as your best always making mistakes
and redoing it i can tell you that i've
experienced those types of seasons and
and in that one of the things that i've
had to really remember
is this phrase heather it's your race at
your pace and that means that if i need
to take some time for some self-care or
if i need to take some time to really
invest more time into my children or
into my marriage that that is okay that
we are multifaceted human beings and
that this is a long race and so it needs
to be your race at your pace and i want
to encourage you that if you're feeling
you know anxiety if you're feeling
overwhelmed to just take a step back and
really maybe reflect on the gratitude in
your life and maybe reflect on when was
the last time you really
rested and for me personally that's the
place i have to go and i have to really
internalize a lot of those things
because i still care what people think
about me and because of that that means
that i put extra pressure on myself to
be a performer to show up as my best to
have people like me and over the years
as i'm approaching 40 eventually can i
say that to you here on the podcast as
i'm approaching 40 and have you know
heading into the season of teenage years
with my kids and i've been married for
over 15 years and been doing this thing
as content creation and digital
marketing for the last decade i can tell
you that it is a long game and i want to
be here for it i want to know that this
is something that i can sustain for the
next 20 30 40 years so that i can make a
big impact in the world and i hope that
encourages you that over time i've just
noticed that we think we can accomplish
more in one year and we underestimate
what we can actually accomplish in 10.
so don't put the pressure on yourself to
just make it happen right now remember
that everything in seasons is okay thank
you for being a part of what we're doing
here on the podcast and if you've not
rated or reviewed this show yet i want
you to go over to itunes if you're not
there and rate and review the show and
you might be featured on an upcoming
episode today's featured reviewer is j
vine86 he says a must listen podcast for
creators i've been following the think
media crew for years if you aren't
familiar with them make sure to give
them a follow and listen for the best
marketing tips well thank you so much
for leaving that and i'm so excited that
you've been following the crew here at
think media and it's awesome to be able
to read your reviews on the show well if
you didn't catch our other episode with
modern millie i'll make sure to link
that down in the show notes below or if
you're watching on youtube in the
description if you want to go back and
listen to the part one of this
conversation that sean cannell and
modern millie had thank you for being a
part of what we're doing and we'll catch
you in the next episode
[Music]